what what is what
is does he I don't is he also surprising
me with something I don't know if he
actually is or not I've been wondering
this I'm so confused at what's happening
it's his birthday yeah it
[Applause]
is oh you got the birthday fit on
[Laughter]
huh damn new boot goofing
goofing where did you get those like I
got to be honest man I'm so jealous yeah
shout out to the boy Josh Weissman
Prince Fox he got you those set me up
got me
right got me right [__] this
this is a pointed toe this ain't no
[__] [__] ass you know John Wayne
cut we ain't got no [__] square cut
this is for [__] who get their
foot in a
ass
I'm here Dam I'm large and in charge
yeah I haven't quite figured out how to
rock these yet but no you're rocking
them dude we're getting there you're
rocking them dude let me tell you
something what I'll tell you something
you son [__] uhhuh happy birthday
thanks dude I have a I have a couple
gifts for you you do I do yeah I like
yeah you know while the energy is high
while you're feeling good um I thought
I'd give you these going bring me down I
think the theme of this is that I'm just
not I'm just not a very good Gift Giver
okay that seems to be the general theme
I tried really hard on these and they
all just crashed and burn actually the
first one the first one's not that bad
okay I'd say the first one is my best
one okay I wanted to do something I
wanted to show you that I care okay I'm
ready and that I'm thinking about you
I'm ready and every day you show up here
yeah with a breakfast burrito mhm right
and you you face that thing before we
start I try yeah normally right up to
the buzzer like you're taking your last
bite as we start right and that can only
result in what I imagine is pretty bad
indigestion so maybe some heartburn
maybe so I got you something
here this is a lifetime supply of pepsin
I'll be
stoked yield for the birthday boy oh
yeah bro let's [__] go
yes I like this I like
this what put that right there guess
what check this out what's up
oopsie right
there oh is that
pepid oh is that pepid AC
yay damn cha ching look at that two
hours of relief look at that two
straight hours of relief wow right there
for my boy anytime I need it now I can't
wait till it's hitting me and I don't
have any quarters and I'm
like
that's what do you mean that's a
lifetime supply of quarters what the
right there is this that's a lifetime
supply for two weeks second one I tried
to think what is what does he enjoy
right now mhm and you know how can we
represent that help you represent your
joy for something right so I wanted to
get you something big something that
made a statement right you
know yeah dude
God damn
it I get the sentiment though that would
have been hysterical if that was huge I
know right but now it's just
cool you know what's really great about
that too I just
uninstalled God damn it that's fine and
then the third one this one really was a
just a it felt pretty flat just a doozy
it's a doozy just a big Miss it's what
it's just a m dripper just wearing the
same outfit as
you um yeah I'll just I'll just uh I'll
just show you this is actually hurting
my
eyes but I like this though I'm
definitely taking
this we'll go in my
garage oh [__] oh
[__]
my
turn way
faster sorry get out of
here
[Music]
sorry there is a
reverse is this so is this like you have
to have an AARP card to have
this why is it so
fast so
fast that's such a good way to try to
kill your
grandma sorry hold
on stop right
there stop I thought like so long and
hard about this I'm like he likes cars
let's get him something funny that's
like
looks like a car but it's not a car and
we like Googled for a while and I found
this and then I showed it to somebody
they're like oh the one that H3 has they
did this entire bit with this exact
scooter oh got it and they're like oh
the Gatsby and I'm like yeah that's the
exact one that I got yeah so now it's
already been done they crashed into it
they crashed into yeah they demolished
they crashed it they demolished it so
it's it's it's a done bit got it but
it's actually pretty fun yeah if I race
it
yeah that's different TR yeah if I took
this to the track yeah have a truck I
could do that yeah that's for you got a
big old truck happy birthday thanks dude
if this is actually mine I'm it actually
is I'm 1,000% loading this in my truck
and I'm going to take it to the TRU it's
a th% yours dude I'm going to the track
on Sunday actually you should actually
actually take it to the track can you
are you would you be allowed yeah they
wouldn't care okay yeah oh my God yeah I
I was going to wrap it in my face but
then couldn't figure out how to do that
in time yeah thanks man yeah no problem
yeah pre Happy Birthday go-kart for my
birthday none of them none of these
gifts are as cool as as boots yeah the
boots are pretty that's the best that's
the best gift yeah the this is the gift
that keeps on giving these boots right
here truly I mean they smell good new
boo goofing is like it's Just Energy you
know yeah I really want to wear these
all the time if I'm being honest I feel
more what oh oh yeah and there's a cake
a breakfast burrito cake oh my
goodness dude oh my
god oh yeah that's
appetizing oh yeah I really want to eat
that happy happy 25th thanks man it's so
crazy being 14 three candles sry for 23
dude hey watch the sign man no no no
it's fine it's fine oh man the detail on
this is
disgusting happy birthday yeah yeah
thanks
gang dude you were like plugging those
shoes the ones that make you tall yeah
that's that's what these are I know you
don't even need those [__] I know but
the the problem is you can see the heel
lift on those yeah but no one's looking
at that if they're looking in the eyes
you just keep the conversation up
here oh yeah yeah damn I feel like a
piece of [__] yeah looking at you yeah
little [__] yeah I do damn you just
keep it and if their ey start to drift
lower you're like hey convos up here
yeah yeah convo is up here
yeah